esos dos puntos precisamente el punto de
no asegurar las fronteras
recordemos que yo bailé tuvo algunas
pericias durante el pasado año los
haitianos que estaban tratando de entrar
a la frontera la reacción de la patrulla
fronteriza con látigos que generó toda
una crisis en eeuu y el tema del gasto
público lo mencionó la gobernaba el
gobernador a reynolds diciendo que ellos
los republicanos no le pagaban a los
estadounidenses para quedarse en casa y
no trabajar y no estaban gastando
billones de dólares que estaban
contribuyendo a la inflación la pola la
posible respuesta o defensa de los
demócratas que incluso yo bailén en su
discurso esta noche lo mencionó es que
por ejemplo sin este gasto público a un
tema que puede sonar simple como lo de
las guarderías para los niños sin ese
guard gasto público para financiar las
guarderías el precio a la mitad que
quiere financiar el gobierno a los
padres para que puedan enviar a sus
niños a sus menores a las guarderías sin
eso por ejemplo no permitirían que las
mujeres puedan ir al mercado laboral
muchas mujeres porque las guarderías en
ciudades como washington nueva york o
chicago tienen un costo promedio mensual
de tres mil dólares al mes en promedio
este costo pues lleva a que muchas
madres simplemente prefieran pues dejar
de ir a trabajar a ahorrarse sus tres
mil dólares quedarse en la casa y esto
entonces pues suma a la crisis de la
falta de mano de obra que hay en eeuu y
esto lleva a que obviamente los costos
sean más altos para las empresas que se
traduzcan entonces a los consumidores
finales precisamente porque no hay esa
inversión social en financiar guarderías
para que las madres puedan estar libres
y puedan ir al mercado laboral esa
podría ser entonces una de las defensas
de los demócratas en cuanto a esta
crítica que hacen los republicanos de
que más gasto público pues lleva a más
inflación y pues el tema de la frontera
obviamente se puede refutar por parte de
los demócratas al argumentar que es muy
difícil pues en este momento cuando hay
un conflicto en europa cuando hay una
ola migratoria
de muchos ucranianos no solamente a
europa sino que pronto se empezará a ver
a eeuu y cuando se retira de eeuu de la
guerra de más de 20 años de afganistán y
eso genera obviamente una ola migratoria
de refugiados también de afganistán pues
hablar de cerrar las fronteras creo que
va en contra del contexto global en este
momento por el que pasa eeuu y por el
rol que debe asumir eeuu como pues líder
del mundo y por la responsabilidad que
tuvo en estos conflictos